avec nous ce soir alain creton qui est
propriétaire du restaurant chez
alexandre à montréal qui président
également de l'association des
restaurants et des commerçants de la rue
peel à montréal bonsoir monsieur creton
cl oui mais cnil qui est co propriétaire
des restaurants cosmos à québec monsieur
maintenir le bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
creton d'abord je vous demande une
première réaction aux annonces que que
je rappelle et je veux simplement bien
les détails et pour que les gens
comprennent bien c'est une réduction
essentiellement de la capacité des lieux
à 50%
l'interdiction de la danse le karabakh
ok les personnes doivent demeurer à 6
etc on revient à ces mesures-là votre
première réaction de sucre et on
écoute et à l'ehpad rôle d'abord aller
pas drôle parce qu'ils nous ont annoncé
sa lumière et lui on avait deux belles
journées pour les parties de bureaux à
travers toute la province et est
aujourd'hui demain et après demain et là
maintenant du jour au lendemain on nous
tous nos revenus en disant c'est fini
restez chez vous terminez tous les
partis du bureau ont été annulés à
travers toute la province surtout les
amis restaurateurs et scandaleux
aurait-il pu attendre lundi avant de
nous asservir du roi et clients c'est
scandaleux
c'est à dire que les c'est à dire
monsieur croteau les nouvelles mesures
c'est à partir de lundi à partir du
lundi 20 décembre mais puisqu'il ya eu
des annonces au cours des dernières
heures derniers jours il ya déjà un
effet sur vos activités hors média comme
l'était à tous les partis du haut de
chez alexandre comme chez mes collègues
ont été allumées toute la thyroïde et
c'est est plus drôle du tout si on pas
monsieur maintenir votre réaction vous
de votre côté monsieur maintenir comment
ça se passe dans les restaurants cosmos
ben on a quand même eu beaucoup beaucoup
de casse et la
ministère puis on eu quand même pas mal
de panique je te dirai
moi j'assume à un traiteur qui vaut lui
vaut quand même très bien les
restaurants sont très grands donc le 50
pour seize romans tirés possi paix parce
que j'ai quand même un problème de main
d'oeuvre qui est encore long puis
est-ce que des coûts inespérés
discothèque se sait ce que pop dance
fait catastrophique mais je suis il
vient quand même parce que quand je vois
le nombre de cas qu'ils ont nommée
tantôt sont pures et les sucres possible
doit être bien content la seule chose je
voudrais quand même rajouter c'est que
les gens
je trouve que les gens ont pas de
tolérance qu'est-ce que vous le dire on
appâte maintenant qui nous manque un
produit sur le menu vous avez pas dit
non on n'a pas été livré on vit quand
même avec beaucoup de bach aux deux
accusés - dans l'es6 présentement on un
problème ou si l'un d'eux moi j'ai fait
le stationnement aujourd'hui puis je
vois que les gens peuvent quand même à
est assez impatient l'alitement
dirigeants plus conciliant ça veut dire
quoi en terme de coût monsieur creton de
chiffre d'affaires cette période de
l'année qui tout à coup la vous glisse
un peu sous les pieds
pour écouter au mieux j'espère qu'on
sera réduit de 50 % à que plein d'autres
capacités mais définitivement elle ça
risque d'être de 70% moindre de ce qu'on
espérait l'obs et que c'est vraiment
très très important non seulement pour
moi mais pour tous les collègues sera de
chantage et de chez alexandre on est de
90 mais en plus 50% chez alexandre
peut-être comme mon collègue de québec
on s'en sortira et d'autres qui pourront
pas survivre à 50% ces sites qui prouve
que ce
c'est vraiment trop difficile récemment
on avait fait une entrevue avec monsieur
mousseau à montréal qui devait être
vraiment au bout de la piste l'an
quelque sorte en termes de solutions à
québec par exemple est ce que vous vous
connaissez des gens ou est ce que vous
croyez que cette situation c'est un coup
de grâce pour plusieurs restaurateurs
ça dépend
du financement des aides financières
mois à date le premier col vite qu'on
ait eu si j'avais voulu monsieur trudeau
je serai fermer définitivement
puis le provincial martin marié donné
alors j'espère qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
quelque chose à ce moment si
l'administration vous souhaitez monsieur
mcneil que des soutifs mois qui viennent
quelque chose qui peut nous aider parce
qu'on a au niveau provincial mauges
absolument les programmes y en avait
mais y en a point que je tenais vraiment
monsieur creton qu'est ce que ce matin
vous avez publié un communiqué pour dire
que le gouvernement ne vous a pas
consultés
et donc ça vous fâchez que vous n'étiez
pas consultés pourquoi le gouvernement
devrait vous consultez
bien écouté comme j'ai dit auparavant on
connais tu es en plein partie du bureau
est ce que c'était vraiment est ce qu'il
y avait vraiment corriger nos amis
suissesse qui avait le feu au lac pour
vous ne pas nous donner nos deux grandes
journées de party de bureau de fait
c'est ça qui est et qui était
scandaleuse du jour au lendemain au dos
levier prix dans les restaurants c'est
exactement ça que ça voulait dire que là
je trouve que c'est scandaleux de ne pas
avoir consulté l'association des
restaurateurs à leurs fonds été les
premiers touchés à montréal dans le
centre ville et puis gens d'affaires
donc monsieur maintenir les ce qu'on
oublie un peu le temps des fêtes en tout
cas une partie du chiffre d'affaires
habituel et janvier-février
janvier-février je ne crois pas que
c'est les meilleurs mois là pour la
restauration mais on le sait les perds
mon c les pires moi donc ça ressemble à
quoi dans votre esprit là à quoi
ressemblent les prochaines semaines
et posté moi j'ai pas si grosse baisse
[Musique]
du mois je vois bien m'a tiré parce
qu'on a eu quand même une neuf derniers
mois était extraordinaire parce qu'on
avait de la subvention parce qu'on a eu
de l'aide parce qu'on peut reprocher à
nos loyers puis j'ai beaucoup de
restaurateurs du québec qui me disent
que
c'est leur meilleure année au niveau des
bailleurs fait que
je suis pas en mauvaise position c'est
ce que moi mon resterait signé pays ce
que qui gouvernent york 4 ans qu'elle
n'irait comptes à payer et c'est europe
et qu'un petit restaurant il y arrive
pas c'est sûr que là dessus j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup dead mais il va quand
même tendu des colts ont rodion hong
hong et imaginatif légende la
restauration vous êtes résident si
ça demande beaucoup de résilience en
tout cas monsieur creton ah oui mais
quand on travaille pas des no tav non
plus ouais mais c'est aux moines mais
moi je ne voudrais pas trahi notre
talent présent nous autres on va du
bonheur enfin que oui c'est off mais je
suis un gros tacle de travailler dans la
restauration encore ok vous emmener de
l'espoir ça fait du bien monsieur creton
en terminant près écoutez nous on est
des marchands de bonheur moi je suis pas
moi je veux que les gens viennent me
voir je veux partager avec eux je suis
pas un traiteur comme le sua la chance
d'être prêteur tant mieux mais moi je
suis un marchand de bonheur dans une
brasserie française beaucoup de mes
collègues sont appréhendées des
marchands de bonheur on veut avoir des
gens je veux avoir des subventions jeu
juste avoir des clients jugés pour des
clients satisfaits jusqu'à ni mon argent
par moi même avec le beau jonathan
correction avec le bonheur qu'on entend
derrière vous parce qu'il ya quand même
du monde dans votre restaurant ce soit
monsieur creton remercie et monsieur
maintenir merci bonne chance pour la
suite bonne chance à tout le monde
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit